the Joe Rogan experience sometimes
that's just the way things are it's just
the way people are to wear it like they
they want to see like you add the food
they want to see that controversy and
they want they want to see that
negativity all the time yeah it's like
mass is it's like a do like steep a if
steep a can't get a look and he's like a
firefighter like legitimately saving
lives on a daily basis Wow like training
to death and then a world champion at it
it's like man if I do like that can't
get no love I'll stand a chance bro but
you know I'm happy to see it these are
always gonna work out the way they
supposed to work out you know what I
mean I guess but I just felt like the
marketing of him could have been so much
better that was my feeling on that it's
like how do you miss out on this here oh
yeah I mean man it's super exciting I
think it's just American culture maybe
cuz you see like one Fc doesn't
necessarily be the same way you know and
they're still doing great I mean time
will tell how great they really do but
but their way of marking and a guy and
promoting them and everything is just so
much different mm-hmm it's like does
that work in America is the problem is
that people only want to see what they
want to see like even about me you know
like people see me kind of hit chiesa at
the press conference and then that's all
they really know about me so that's all
they really you know they think that's
me or more and they they even read wrong
it to that type of situation and they
just think that's how you is but did you
ever talk to Casa after your fight with
him yes cool hey uncle he's pissed is
the choke no I think he's just mad away
the whole situation exhaust the choke I
mean it's almost like no he would have
been better off if he went to sleep yeah
but he you know yeah I mean he even said
is that yeah I mean I'm he's mad that
the fight went down the way you know
young wraps it around but but he's more
mad still that I hit him it's what if
the problem was it was so locked in yeah
stop it right there like let him go out
let him tap or go out yeah but but but
thing is it's it's defend yourself you
know japa choke you don't stop a choke
if the guys awake you don't stop a choke
that's
I mean there there's been a couple
situations where we're you know that'll
kind of happen and the guy will stop
defending himself and the ref will will
stop it and the refs do tell you they're
like they're like if you stop defending
yourself then you know it would out what
else is there to do I mean yeah they
could I you could just let me choke him
out and have been a little easier but
for us as competitors we kind of know
you know I think he just was more upset
it didn't know as well yeah Ethan goes
way in and they're not the way but look
people even wrong into that into that
kind of situation like I'm a cool dude I
I mean I mean I don't mean to say like
that but I'm I'm always gonna give
respect to everybody you know that's
just the way I kinda a.m. until you kind
of diminish that respect for me then
then you know I'm gonna give it to you
so right I was talking a little bit to
him you know I'm now kind of you know
I'm up there I'm having fun it's my
first big press conference like I'm
having fun at it but the minute that he
got up and in ran across the towards me
it's like there's this dividing line
almost it's like as soon as you step
over that you in my space now it's too
close okay yeah I'm a hit you play like
that's just the way I you know you also
you're in a defensive position like you
have to hit them almost yeah yeah once
someone comes at you in the right this
is a fight yeah it's a fight I mean I
that's just the way I grew up you know
is anytime in each party some somebody
is gonna you know invade your space like
you're not gonna wait you guys could
rematch sometime at 170 170 that's very
possible
a lot of the fights well he was another
guy that had a real hard time making
that way he's a big fella yeah yeah I
mean they roll back on them and for me
it's like I've always just wanted a fair
fight so you know we can win at whatever
you know it's it's even with me and dos
Santos I was saying you know let's weigh
in at 165 and just kind of shutting hand
he didn't want to do it but I'm like I
just want a fair fight out of the deal
you know it's whatever you want to weigh
in we can shake hands to fight it want
to weigh in at 165 just to show that
this weight class is a viable weight
class I tried to anyone do it yeah he
said I don't make agreements with my
opponents
and I was like come on you know like
this is our problem in the first place
there's why ain't no Union or nothing
you know I mean like everybody's like
against each other like come on bro we
fight in any way